Jake Paul breaks his silence about his
brothers YouTube controversy plus the
Oscar nominations are out and we're
celebrating with this year's nominees
[Music]
roll out the red carpet y'all because
the nominations for the 90th Academy
Awards yes 90 were announced today but
first I got to get to Jake Paul you guys
because he is finally speaking out about
his brother Logan's controversial
suicide forest video Jake shared his
thoughts in a 13 minute video on YouTube
most of which is Jake and his friends
pranking each other but he does however
saved the last two minutes to defend his
brother I don't think it's right what he
did at all and I know Logan more than
probably anybody else and I do know
though that he did not mean to offend
anyone and I could I could tell when
he's like in shock and and he didn't
handle the situation in the right way
but I know in the back of his head he
didn't mean to offend her or hurt
anybody or create such a big frustration
and he is honestly truly truly sorry as
I told you guys earlier this month
you to cut some ties with Logan and put
his projects on hold in light of the
whole situation his brother Jake says
that not only is Logan paying for the
huge mistake he made but he's learning
from it to let me know your guys's
thoughts in the comments section below
will Logan bounce back all right we're
gonna hard pivot here cuz it's a big day
in Hollywood with this year's Oscar
nominations it's been a morning full of
surprises but none more epic than
first-time nominee Allison Janney et's
the shell Turner went to celebrate with
the I Tania star on the set of her show
maan and it got out of hand literally so
this is cool
champagne cork bomber is everyone okay
that is the best thing I've seen all day
and you know what ll Allison isn't the
only one celebrating today in fact we
all should be because based on the
nominations today you can tell that the
Academy really embraced Outsiders this
year the shape of water a movie about a
mute woman black cleaning lady and a gay
man rescuing a sea monster racked up 13
nominations the most of any film this
year and the directing category was the
most diverse in years including Mexico
born guillermo del toro for shape of
water and Jordan Peele he's nominated
for directing one of my favorite movies
of the year get out and he is only the
fifth black director ever to be
nominated in this category he was also
nominated for Original Screenplay and
this morning Jordan called his get out
leading man Daniel Correa who woke up to
a nomination of his own
Jordan tweeted how that combo went down
you know when you're on the phone trying
to disguise the sound of an ugly cry I
failed at that meanwhile Lady Bird
director Greta Gerwig is now the fifth
woman ever to be nominated in the
category and she is also nominated for
her screenplay for the love letter to
Sacramento
she told et today in a statement quote I
am struggling to find the words to
express how much the nomination for Best
Director and Best Screenplay means to me
in a year where there are so many
brilliant films by so many of my heroes
of cinema all I can say is thank you
from the bottom of my heart it was also
a year of firsts one name trending big
this morning was Rachel Morrison she's
the first woman ever to be nominated for
Best Cinematography for mud bound which
is absolutely major and her Muse in that
movie mary j blige is a double nominee
and the first to ever score nominations
for both an acting and original song
Oscar in the same
here as you guys know we've been rooting
for her all award season long as well as
my boy Timothy shell of may who at 21
just became the youngest person
nominated for Best Actor in 75 years
he told ET he still is shocked and I say
I called it in case you guys missed it
go watch why we're obsessed with Timmy
sha'lame right now all right as you can
tell I get excited for these things and
if you do too while the full list of
nominees for the 90th Academy Awards is
up on our site ET online.com and we also
have more reactions through some of your
nominees so go check it out now see you
guys tomorrow
[Music]